THOUGHT, THOUGH.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> THAT'S A WOW FACTOR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE ACMs.
THE COUNTRY DUO BROTHERS
OSBOURNE IS UP FOR TWO AWARDS AT
SUNDAY'S ACADEMY OF COUNTRY
MUSIC AWARDS INCLUDING ALBUM OF
THE YEAR FOR THEIR THIRD STUDIO
ALBUM "SKELETONS."
THEY'LL ALSO PERFORM ON SUNDAY.
WE RECENTLY MET UP WITH THE
BROTHERS IN THEIR HOMETOWN OF
DEALE, MARYLAND, ON THE
CHESAPEAKE, AFTER WHAT HAS BEEN
SOME OF THE BIGGEST AND MOST
TRANSFORMATIONAL YEARS OF THEIR
LIVES.
TJ OSBORNE TALKED ABOUT HIS
DECISION TO PUBLICLY COME OUT AS
GAY THIS PAST FEBRUARY, AND JOHN
REVEALED FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT
HE EXPERIENCED A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN 2019 AS THE BAND WAS
HEADING INTO THE STUDIO TO WORK
ON ITS LATEST ALBUM.
HERE'S A CLIP OF OUR
CONVERSATION.
>> I REMEMBER TELLING OUR
MANAGER AT THE TIME, I TOLD HIM
-- I CAN'T GO IN THE STUDIO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG WITH
ME.
I'M NOT HAPPY.
I'M DEPRESSED.
MY ANXIETY IS THROUGH THE ROOF.
I CAN'T SLEEP.
MY EARS ARE RINGING.
>> YOU WERE RELUCTANT TO SAY
ANYTHING?
>> I WAS VERY RELUCTANT TO SAY
ANYTHING.
WE GREW UP IN A CULTURE WHERE IF
YOU FELL AND SKINNED YOUR KNEE,
GET UP, DON'T CRY, WALK IT OFF.
AND YOU KNOW, THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
BE PERS IS -- DILIGENT.
>> WERE YOU WORRY ABOUT HIM?
>> ALL THE TIME.
ON STAGE I COULD TELL HE DID NOT
WANT TO BE THERE.
THAT'S WHEN I WAS LIKE, WOW, WE
NEED TO GO HOME NOW.
WE ENDED UP CANCEL SOMETHING
DATES.
WE CANCELED FARM AID WHICH WAS
LIKE A DREAM OF OURS TO DO.
THIS WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IN THE WORLD WAS TO GET
JOHN BACK IN A HEALTHY PLACE.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
WOW.
IT WAS -- IT WAS -- I MEAN, JOHN
SAYS HE ACTUALLY CONSIDERED
QUITTING COUNTRY MUSIC WHICH HE
NEVER THOUGHT HE WOULD BE IN A
POSITION OF DOING.
>> INTERESTING HE SAID HIS
BROTHER LOOKED AT HIM AND KNEW.
>> YEAH.
>> HE WAS ACTUALLY -- HE WAS
ACTUALLY ON STAGE AT THAT MOMENT
WITH BONNIE RAITT, WILLY NELSON,
AND ALLISON KRAUSS.
LIKE A DREAM SHOW.
HE WAS IN A REALLY BAD PLACE.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH PEOPLE.
>> I'M GLAD TO SEE YOU WITH
PEOPLE, TALKED TO PEOPLE --
>> I WAS SO EXCITED TO GO TO
DEALE, MARYLAND, I CAN'T TELL
YOU.
>> I WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL IN THAT
COUNTY.
IT IS GORGEOUS.
ANNE ARUNDEL COUNTY, MARYLAND.
>> VERY RURAL AND ON THE WATER.
IT'S STUNNING.
AND YOU CAN HEAR MORE FROM
BROTHERS OSBORNE THIS SUNDAY ON
"CBS SUNDAY MORNING" AND MONDAY
ON "CBS THIS MORNING."
>> I WONDER IF THEY SAY WATER
LIKE I DO